hello and welcome to see you're playing
FM house of fun this croatia i still
have problems with those flags even the
or Krishna koha a professional pianist
all right it's not a bad job I guess
okay this Bishop f5 line is quite
comfortable for wired so and we'll see
how this and how this unfolds and I'd
like to get in a quick before heaven and
beforehand and ok ok I'll go be fine but
let's start with this
yeah white has more space on the
queenside blacks play is usually related
to Bishop d8 Bishop c7 and then shooting
form e 5 and okay plays it a bit
differently we'll see b5 or is that too
early okay I'll shoot 45 and sometimes
there are tactics oh I don't think this
is one of those situations okay hmm but
isn't this rather dangerous here now one
night takes you five huh he wants to go
night takes you five let's mean that is
mean
hmm hey it's a real problem here may
takes you five okay but I have queen
chubby for right it's not takes on two
695 queen before does he have a good
move that I don't know how maybe you can
just take right and you can just take
okay if I take your form I think pawn
takes Knight e5 and it's the ton of
trades I don't know if that is so great
but anyway I cannot wait any longer he
saw he says this is going to be on
YouTube again yes it is
okay Quintus is seven this is a double
attack I'm not double attack but it's a
taxi five hmm it's a bit of a problem
here
I don't like it so much really heavy
Quincy three okay so look here yeah it's
not really great in all right okay seven
so look to the five yeah this is really
not anything huh I didn't oh I just
blundered this porn that's not good I
got a bit distracted by the chetia he
chatted a bit with me I don't mind that
so I'd excuse or anything but I simply
got a bit distracted didn't see that it
was hanging hmm do a shame him it's not
a position out of the opening that white
should ever lose actually it's very
one-sided but if you play badly you can
use any position okay
need to get rid of the room p.m. okay my
this is ok again i don't think i'm going
to lose that one I mean maybe on time
but I spent far too much time but not on
position anymore rg3 will give three no
not a problem tires I have to ship g2
coming I just want to attack this pawn
now
and he's not winning many endgames he
are not winning four against three
check the solution is a draw maybe he
wants to try I mean he has more time and
his good morning about dome jective Lee
speaking this is a drawer I think
ashanti for I have to be a little bit
cautious than I'm not running into some
completely wacky and temple stuff just
keep this here there's no way forward
check it's just a fortress
the only negative thing is I cannot
completely pre move here because he has
that age for move always in store
rawhide really you want to play this on
time it's a little bit can kind of check
and interesting czech girl Alfred yeah
it wasn't a particularly good game right
I just blundered this this damn e5 pawn
but he had a good counter play idea here
with night xe5 that was Sir was kind of
neat here he just said that was close
yeah that's true ok so this was an
interesting idea interesting counterplay
idea if i take here yes I thought he has
this move but in fact it doesn't do ok I
can just take here hmm I was stupid then
I thought that would work but of course
I can take here I'd check and computers
merciless ok so then I should take this
of course and planned coup and then look
from here this is actually nice now and
this is this is a much stronger version
of the game
like this this this now I can go Queen B
6 or woke a 6 or something like that I'm
the game we had this and now i played
this move and it should take which will
probably transpose and now queen to be
625 rook be one okay so he cannot defend
this yeah then white is a bit better
because this is looking looking a bit
stupid yeah I didn't I certainly I
simply blunt at that pawn and yeah it's
just blundered he fire here bishops his
six is still alright yeah this is ok
it's a bit weird looking self in but
this Bishop is not playing at all ok so
we had this and now he's a pawn up and
has chances but I think I don't think
that this quick f4 was so great actually
I think he I should be ok his Bishop is
very bad and it really this is the pawn
that he has extra and it doesn't really
mean much I think from here i should
draw okay here okay three was better
okay this this and he has this more
threatening you three okay to that was
the opportunity I think here check here
is just a draw yeah that's funny has
stopped fish still gives black 0.7 which
is of course wrong edges the dead draw
and if it's a fortress basically I keep
the King on f 2 point and h4n just
shuffle there is no way I'm getting into
zoosk Vanya okay thanks for watching